What has Melissa Rauch done to convince
her kids she's part of the judicial
system? Her career went in a slightly different
direction after "The Big Bang Theory" ended.
Melissa Rauch bid her character Dr. Bernadette
Rostenkowski-Wolowitz goodbye on "The Big Bang
Theory" more than four years ago. With her
adorable facade and cut-throat actions,
Bernadette is one of the most intriguing "Big Bang
Theory" characters. Not only is the mother of two
a brilliant scientist, but she also managed
something incredible: getting her husband,
Simon Helberg's Howard Wolowitz, to suppress
his proclivity for being sleazy around women.
Rauch also put on a cartoon-like voice when
portraying Bernadette. For this reason,
it should come as no surprise that she has
been a successful voice actor following
"The Big Bang Theory." Take a look at
her filmography and you'll see that
the actor brought animated characters
to life for the kid-friendly shows,
"Firebuds" and "The Chicken Squad." In
addition, when she is not in a recording studio,
Rauch puts on her executive producer hat for
the "Night Court" reboot. She also has been
showing off her comedy skills as the show's
protagonist, Judge Abracadabra "Abby" Stone.
Rauch discussed the "Night Court"
reboot in a February 2023 interview
on the "Jennifer Hudson Show." The New
Jersey native shared that she believes
those unfamiliar with the comedy's source
material would like the new show just as
much as hardcore fans. She hinted that
her character inherited her father's
inability to hide his whimsy, even while
wearing his judge robe. The actor shared,
"What I love about it is that people
who loved the original incarnation,
there's so much for them that they
will remember and nostalgia and
just all these little Easter eggs that
they will remember from the original."
"And then for people who don't have any prior
knowledge of it, they can come into it with
fresh eyes and they don't need to have,
you know, that familiarity with it either."
While Rauch clearly takes pride in her work,
it seems that her children might not be quite
as enthusiastic about her job. Even though her
kids, Brooks and Sadie, may have enjoyed a few
episodes of "Firebuds" and "The Chicken Squad,"
it's unlikely they are that aware their mother is
an actor on the animated shows. While speaking to
Hudson, the "Big Bang Theory" star explained that
her son and daughter are under the impression
that she actually works in a court of law.
"Is it wrong that I haven't corrected them?"
"No you can keep it in your back pocket."
"They've seen the posters for it and they're
like, 'Mom's a judge!' And I'm like, 'Yes, I am.'"
During a February 2023 appearance on "The View,"
Rauch shared that there have been some tricky
aspects about appearing in "Night Court." She
noted that some "Big Bang Theory" viewers may
find watching the 2023 sitcom jarring because she
did not change her natural voice. The actor joked,
"I don't tend to read a lot of Instagram
comments but I did notice that people were
concerned that I wasn't using the same
voice that I use for Bernadette on 'Big
Bang.' The reaction is a little bit
like when you are transitioning from
silent movies into talkies. Like people are
horrified that I'm not talking like that."
However, Rauch does not seem to
mind being associated with her
"Big Bang Theory" character. The actor
helped contribute to the 2022 book,
"The Big Bang Theory: The Definitive,
Inside Story of the Epic Hit Series."
During an October 2022 interview with the book's
author, Jessica Radloff, Rauch shared that she
missed the CBS comedy for several reasons. She
noted that she longed for the days that she could
regularly interact with "The Big Bang Theory"
cast and crew — but it's not just her coworkers
she missed. She apparently was also very fond
of the omelet bar that was set up for the show's
stars once a week. Either way, it seems she has as
much love for her time on the show as her fans do.